pas tu veux passer sur le corps beans
est l'histoire d'une adolescente de 12
ans qui à l'été 1990 est plongé dans la
tourmente de la crise d'oka et il
partage ce récit semi autobiographique
et celui de la réalisatrice moix oui
c'est dire traumatisé par cette crise
sow ou ce moment a volé mon innocence
mon sentiment de sécurité et mon estime
de soi faire ce film fait partie d'un
processus de guérison dit elle les gens
comme vous ils sont pas les bienvenus
ici quoi cette série being met en scène
le racisme et la violence vécue lors des
78 jours d'affrontements entre les
marques et une partie de la population
c'était un racisme très violent et un
très très ouvert le 100ème édition c'est
très important de présenter un la la
perspective du point de vue de la nation
aura que ce que tout cela les vêtements
ça coûte cher territoire pour bien
montrer le quotidien d'une adolescente
prise en plein milieu de la crise d'oka
cette fiction utilise des images d
archives pour illustrer que la réalité
dépasse parfois la fiction les archis
sont très heureux à regarder je crois
que les médias dans ces années là ne
faisait pas beaucoup de censure dont il
ya des choses vraiment horrible qui se
sont aussi dans les médias dans les
nouvelles tout les roachs autochtone de
ce film sont joués par des autochtones
et pour la version en français
on a fait appel à saint yan et à natasha
khan était fontaine pour le doublage des
rôles principaux
moi même et mes deux enfants qui sont
aussi dans les films vraiment heureux et
je pense en fait que c'est le meilleur
temps pour qu'ils sortent parce que on
sent un vent de changement au sein de la
population au québec mais aussi à
travers le pays notre peuple souffre tu
comprends après avoir été présenté dans
35 e festival au cours de la dernière
année
binz débarque d'alice nema québécois
aujourd'hui puis dans le reste du canada
le 30 juillet
[Musique]
ici oui philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal